let's start off with a difficult
question how do you
define reality what is truly real
is it simply a case of what we can see
if something is known
as fact and can be proven to exist
does this make it real is reality just
the world around
us or is there something more
the goal of these questions isn't to
make you question every part of the
world around you or to question whether
or not we are all living in a computer
simulation no
you're asked this to help you understand
reality
because first of all we aren't living in
a simulation
we're living in a sitcom there is a
wide-ranging debate on what the most
powerful and dangerous scps ever
encountered are
but there is no denying the ever-present
danger of scp-3812
this ketter class entity is regarded as
highly aggressive by the o5 council
especially as it has only ever been
partially contained
never fully the true scope of its
abilities is currently
unknown and any available information on
scp-3812 is kept classified and secure
by the foundation
needless to say this entity poses a
direct threat not only to the scp
foundation
but to the very fabric of reality itself
contained within the file for scp-3812
is an excerpt from an article by one dr
robert scranton titled supersession
and the echelon of reality in this
article dr scranton posits a theory
about the nature of reality
and understanding him is the first step
towards understanding
scp-3812 his recursive stack theory
states that there are different layers
to reality
but also that no single universe is real
an easy way to think of it is to imagine
a sitcom
any sitcom you can envision will do
between us and the fictional world of a
sitcom
there are multiple observable stacked
universes
firstly our universe the real world as
we experience
it forms the baseline so imagine this
sitting at the top of the stack
next down in the stack comes the sitcom
a fictional universe filled with
characters which fits below
our universe then think of what is
fiction within the fiction
of the sitcom perhaps another television
show
one that only exists in the world of the
sitcom but not in our own
this is the recursive stack infinitely
layered universes and it is crucial you
can envision
and remember this model dr scranton's
theory suggests that any universe
even our own could potentially exist as
a fictional narrative within another
wider universe this wider universe in
which ours is a fiction
could also itself be a narrative within
an even wider universe stacked above it
and so on it's interesting to picture
reality this way
isn't it in fact i'm willing to bet that
you're wondering
maybe there's a universe above ours or
even one above that
would the universe right at the top of
the stack be the truly real world
and what if you could travel between
each stacked reality
if you're asking any of those questions
then congratulations
you sound exactly like scp-3812
scp-3812 was previously known as sam
howell
while little is known about his life sam
was as far as anyone knew
regarded as a fairly ordinary human
being
until his death in 1996 shortly after
which sam
rose from his grave and disappeared it
is unknown whether scp-3812 simply
imitated the form of sam howell
or if they are one and the same as this
entity has been known to have the
ability to change
forms at will making it hard for the
foundation to track it
it does usually maintain a humanoid
appearance however this has deteriorated
somewhat over numerous decades
by now you may have already gathered
that the extent of scp-3812's abilities
don't
end at shape-shifting this scp is a
powerful
aggressive reality altering entity cast
your mind back to the recursive stack
scp-3812 is able to travel upwards
through these stacked universes
creating untold chaos using its plethora
of world-bending abilities
as far as the scp foundation can tell
3812's sole intention is to become an
omnipotent force existing above
any and all possible universes in other
words
the top of the stack aside from the
ability to change shape
scp-3812's control and alteration of
reality around it is achieved by its
long
list of latent abilities this entity is
capable of feats far beyond that of
normal humans
such as teleportation telekinesis and
telepathy
however scp-3812 is also able to
directly manipulate
any and all aspects of reality it can
influence and alter observable forces
around us
for example the manipulation of matter
energy weather
and even gravity and other laws of
physics as we know them
but the creature can also warp reality
on further levels
it's able to erase people objects or
even concepts to the point where
human beings lose virtually all memory
of them
with the danger that an entity this
powerful poses to our reality
it's not surprising that the scp
foundation would attempt to
nullify its abilities one attempt by the
foundation involved another
unknown scp which created an
anti-metaphysical
field this was done in the hopes that it
would strip scp-3812 of its reality
warping abilities
however the entity was unfazed the
containment attempt failed and the
remains of the unknown scp
instead resulted in the creation of
scp-239
as for the scp-3812 entity's own origin
that is still largely unknown but there
does exist a message on a secure server
in the scp foundation's
o5 command seemingly from another entity
belonging to a reality stacked higher
above our own
that appears to have created a reality
much further down
one that scp-3812 inhabited and now it
seems that scp-3812 is climbing
up the stack there is a trade-off of
swords to the abundance of powers
scp-3812 possesses
the entity is in an almost constant
state of ascension through different
stacked universes
climbing higher and higher believing
every reality beneath it to be a fiction
the creature has developed multiple
severe mental conditions that seem to be
a direct result of
overexposure to different layers of
reality this includes an advanced form
of enigman veter schizophrenia complex
which often manifests in extreme
symptoms within the creature
scp-3812 has been known to suffer from
paranoia
dysphoria depression and inability to
control its emotions as well as hearing
voices
seeing things that do not exist and
possessing multiple personalities
while the creature is usually aimless
scp-3812 has been known to have random
outbursts
that can cause anomalies within local
space and time
but thanks to it experiencing so many
different layers of reality
traveling upwards through what it
perceives to be fictional universes
scp-3812 displays difficulty in
separating what is real
and what is imagined in fact reality and
fiction have become one in the same to
scp-3812
because as far as it is concerned they
literally
are the same each new reality it
inhabits is just fiction for the reality
stacked above it
so then how are we supposed to contain
or neutralize such a powerful reality
altering creature
that cannot distinguish between what is
real and what is fictional
the foundation knows that its own
procedures to keep scp-3812 contained
would be
ineffective this entity by its nature
cannot be
contained any attempt to keep it locked
away would easily be undone by any one
of its numerous powers to warp reality
locking it in a cement box at the bottom
of the ocean would be pointless
it could teleport out or turn its cell
into nothing but dust
putting it in a vat of acid to endlessly
burn it would just result in it turning
that acid to harmless water or
air scp-3812 can manipulate events
throughout time
and so it could easily prevent itself
from ever being contained
it is even possible that any individuals
even foundation staff who may have
previously tried to lock the creature up
now no longer exists thanks to
scp-3812's abilities
and there would be no way to determine
this since we wouldn't be able to
remember that the person had ever been
in our reality the foundation's best
hope is to keep scp-3812 where it is
and hope it remains docile if they are
able to keep it away from large
population centers
then the risk of 3812 having any sort of
psychic
influence over citizens or warping
reality and causing the deaths of
millions
or even billions is at least reduced
but of course it is never fully gone on
at least one occasion
scp-3812 has caused a truly catastrophic
event
for some reason scp-3812 decided to turn
itself into a star
spinning endlessly and it did so
numerous anomalous occurrences took
place across the world
most notably scp-3812 caused the
foundation's nuclear warheads to
detonate
spreading harmful radioactive material
into the atmosphere
additionally the population of new
zealand began to sporadically disappear
and reappear looping back and forth
between existence and
non-existence for a period of around 5
hours
it was during this world ending scenario
that scp-3812
still at the center of its star form was
recorded ranting
its split personalities arguing one of
the creatures personalities claimed it
was
unmaking the world as an act of revenge
against someone
it stated that it believed existence is
a joke
the narrative abandoned us to be
miserable and we are breaking
the narrative its other half mentioned
another entity known
only as ben and seemed to imply that
this entity was responsible for
scp-3812's creation
in a reality stacked above this one
according to the more rational of 3812's
two halves
this ben entity deemed us unfit to rest
peacefully
to slip into the darkness quietly he
made a game of us
it then went on to convince this other
half that destroying this reality just
to slight ben
would be pointless there would always be
another stacked on top
infinitely so why does this narrative
mean anything to you
it asked it is one of an eternity to
others
it is not special it is not particular
the two sides of scp-3812 argued with
each other
one wanting to destroy all of reality to
spite ben
driven mad by witnessing trillions upon
trillions of universes stacked atop
each other the other half of 3812 saw
peace for itself
ascending above these infinitely stacked
universes finally reaching the top and
becoming free
not a god a star rising in the east
rising away from this all until we are
little more
than a memory of a song it will be
lonely
the other half of the creature replied
we'll have each other scp-3812's other
personality said
i'm afraid said the one intent on
destruction
i am too the other reassured it but that
is no reason to destroy this narrative
eventually scp-3812's personalities
reached agreement
they both left the narrative they were
currently in presumably traveling
upwards to one stacked above our own
while simultaneously remaining in this
universe
still a danger let go of this world
let him rewrite it back to what it was
we aren't part of this
anymore shortly after this event reality
shifted once more
and the entire world reverted back to
how it had been
before records of the end of the world
scenario that had occurred were retained
by high-level administrators and the o5
council
perhaps as a reminder of the destructive
capabilities of the creature
a warning of its potential to change
this reality and any stacked below
or above it fortunately since this
incident
scp-3812 has remained in its docile
aimless state
no longer actively hostile to anyone
that approaches it
it has kept its amorphous star-like
shape and is still very much able to
create disruptions and anomalies
in reality despite keeping scp-3812
constantly monitored at its current
location
in the south pacific ocean the scp
foundation knows that
at any time this entity could trigger
yet another global catastrophe
causing massive damage to planet earth
its population
and beyond that tearing our reality
itself
asunder so we all just better hope our
narrative remains worthwhile
to scp-3812's better half
now check out scp-1861 the crew of the
hms wintershimer
and scp-1765 the sisters
for more reality warping madness from
the scp foundation